what do you think meta learning
is and looks like
now in the five years 10 years will it
look like system i gotta but scaled
what's your sense of what is
what does metal learning look like do
you think great with all the wisdom
we've learned so far yeah great great
question maybe it's good to give
another data point looking backwards
rather than forward so
when when we talk
um in 2019
meta learning
meant something that has changed mostly
through the
revolution of gpt3 and beyond so what
meta-learning management at the time um
was driven by what benchmarks people
care about in metal learning and the
benchmarks were about
a capability to learn about object
identities so it was very much
overfitted to vision and object
classification and the part that was met
about that was that oh we're not just
learning a thousand categories that
imagenet tells us to learn we're gonna
learn
object categories that can be defined
when we interact with the model so
it's interesting to see the evolution
right the way the way this started was
we have a special language that was a
data set a small data set that we
prompted the model with saying hey here
is a new classification task um i i'll
give you one image and the name
which was an integer at the time of the
image and a different image and so on so
you have a small prompt in the form of a
data set a machine learning data set and
then you got then a system that could
then predict or classify these objects
that you just defined kind of on the fly
so
fast forward
it was revealed that
language models are future learners
that's the title of the paper so very
good title sometimes titles are really
good so this one is really really good
because that's that's the point of gpt3
that showed that look
sure we can we can focus on object
classification and how what meta
learning means within the space of
learning object categories this goes
beyond or before rather to also omniglot
before imagenet and so on so there's a
few benchmarks to now all of a sudden
we're a bit unlocked from benchmarks and
through language we can define tasks
right so we're literally telling the
model some logical task or little thing
that we wanted to do
we prompted much like we did before but
now we prompted through natural language
and then
not perfectly i mean these models have
failure modes and that's fine but
no but these models then are now doing a
new task right so they metal learn um
this new capabilities now
now that's where we are now
flamingo
expanded this to visual and language but
it basically has the same abilities you
can teach it for instance
an emergent property was that you can
take pictures of numbers and then do do
arithmetic with the numbers just by
teaching it oh that's i mean when when i
show you three plus six you know i want
you to output nine and and you show it a
few examples and now it does that so it
went way beyond the oh this image net
sort of category categorization of
images that we were a bit stuck maybe
before um this
revelation moment that happened in 2000
i believe it was 19 but it was after we
checked and that way it has solved metal
learning as was previously defined yes
it expanded what it meant so that's what
you say what does it mean so it's an
evolving term um but here is
maybe now looking forward looking at
what's happening um you know obviously
in the community with more modalities um
what we can expect and i would certainly
hope to see the following and this is a
pretty drastic
hope but in five years maybe we chat
again
and
we have a system right a set of weights
that
we can teach it to play starcraft
maybe not at the level of alpha star but
play starcraft a complex game we teach
it through interactions to prompting you
can certainly prompt a system that's
what gato shows to play some simple
atari games so imagine if you start
talking to a system teaching it a new
game showing it examples of you know in
this in this particular game um this
user did something good maybe the system
can even play and ask you questions say
hey i played this game i just played
this game did i do well can you teach me
more so
five maybe to ten years these
capabilities
or what metal learning means will be
much more interactive much more rich and
through domains that we were
specializing right so you see the
difference right we built alpha star
specialized
to play starcraft the algorithms were
general but the weights were specialized
and what what we're hoping is that we
can teach a network to play games to
play any game just using games as an
example through interacting with it
teaching it uploading the wikipedia page
of starcraft like this is
in the horizon and obviously their
details need to be to be filled and
research need to be done but that's how
i see meta learning above which is going
to be beyond prompting it's going to be
a bit more interactive it's going to you
know the system might tell us to give it
feedback after it maybe makes mistakes
or it loses a game
but it's nonetheless very exciting
because if you think about this this way
the benchmarks are already there we just
repurpose them the benchmarks right so
in a way
i like to map the space of
what maybe agi means to say okay like
we went 101 performance
in go in chess in starcraft
the next iteration might be
20 performance across quote unquote all
tasks
right and even if it's not as good it's
fine we we actually we have ways to also
measure progress because we have those
special agents specialized agents um and
so on so this is to me very exciting and
these next iteration models are
definitely hinting at that direction of
progress um which hopefully we can have
there are obviously some things that
could go wrong in terms of we might not
have the tools maybe transformers are
not enough then we must there's some
breakthroughs to come which makes the
field more exciting to people like me as
well of course um but that's
if i if you ask me five to ten years you
might see these models that start to
look more like
weights that are already trained and
then it's more about teaching
or make their metal on what you're
you're trying um
uh you're trying to to induce in terms
of tasks and so on well beyond the
simple now tasks we're starting to see
emerge like you know small arithmetic
tasks and so on so a few questions are
on that this is fascinating uh so
that kind of teaching interactive not so
it's beyond prompting says interacting
with the neural network
that's different than the training
process
so it's different than the
uh
optimization over differentiable
functions this is already trained and
now you're teaching
i mean um
it's almost like akin to the brain then
the the neurons already set with their
connections on top of that you know
using that infrastructure to build up
further knowledge
okay
so
that's a really interesting distinction
that's actually not obvious from a
software engineering perspective
that there's a line to be drawn
because you always think for a neural
network to learn it has to be retrained
trained and retrained but maybe
and prompting is a way of
teaching
and you'll now work a little bit of
context about whatever the heck you're
trying it to do so you can maybe expand
this prompting capability by um making
it interact that's really really yeah by
the way this is not if you look at way
back um at different ways to tackle even
classification tasks so this this is
this comes from from like long-standing
literature in machine learning um what
i'm suggesting could sound to some like
a bit like
um nearest neighbor so needless neighbor
is almost the simplest algorithm
uh that you can
that does not require learning so it has
this interesting like you don't need to
compute gradients and what nearest
neighbor does is you quote unquote have
a data set or upload a data set and then
all you need to do is a way to measure
distance between points
and then to classify a new point you're
just simply computing what's the closest
point in this massive amount of data and
that's my answer so you can think of
prompting in a way as you're uploading
not not just simple points and and you
know the metric is not the distance
between the images or something simple
it's something that you compute that's
much more advanced but in a way it's
very similar right you you simply are
uploading some knowledge to this
pre-trained system in nearest neighbor
maybe the metric is learned or not but
you don't need to further train it and
then now you immediately get a
classifier
out of this right now it's just an
evolution of that concept very classical
concept in machine learning which is um
yeah just learning through what's the
closest point closes by some distance
and that's it
it's an evolution of that and i will say
how how i saw metal learning when we
worked um on a few ideas in in 2016 was
precisely through the lens of
nearest neighbor which is very common in
computer vision community right there's
a very active area of research about how
do you compute the distance between two
images but if you have a good distance
metric you you also have a good
classifier right all i'm saying is now
these distances and and the points are
not just images they're like
words or sequences of
words and images and actions that teach
you something new but
it might be that technique wise
those come back and i will say that it's
not necessarily true that you might not
ever train the weights a bit further
some aspect of metal learning some
techniques in metal learning
do actually do a bit of fine tuning as
it's called they train the weights a
little bit when they get a new task so
as i call the how or or how we're going
to achieve this
um as a deep learner i'm very skeptic
we're going to try a few things whether
it's a bit of training adding a few
parameters thinking of this as nearest
neighbor or just
simply thinking of there's a sequence of
words it's a prefix
and that's the new classifier
we'll see right there's there's the
beauty of research but um but what's
what's important is that is a good goal
in itself that i see as very worthwhile
pursuing for the next stages of
not only meta learning i think this is
basically
what's exciting about machine learning
period to me well the in the interactive
aspect of that is also very interesting
the interactive version of nearest
neighbor
yeah to help you
pull out the
classifier from this giant thing
okay uh is is this the way we can go in
five ten
plus years
uh from any task so sorry from many
tasks to any task
so
and what does that mean like what does
it need to be actually trained on
which point is the network had enough
so what um
what does a network need to learn about
this world in order to be able to
perform any task is it just as simple as
language
image and action or do you need
some set of representative images
uh like
if you only see land images will you
know anything about underwater is that
somehow fundamentally different i don't
know those i mean those are upward
questions i would say i mean the way you
put let me maybe further your example
right if if all you see is land images
but you're reading all about
land and water worlds but in books right
imagine like
would that be enough
good question we don't know but i guess
maybe you can you can you can join us if
you want in our quest to find this
that's that's precisely water world yeah
yes that's precisely i mean the beauty
of
research and and
that's the the the the
the research business we're in i guess
is to figure this out and ask the right
questions and then iterate with with the
whole community
um publishing like
findings and so on uh but yeah these are
this is a question it's not the only
question but it's certainly as you ask
is is on my mind constantly right and so
we'll we'll need to wait for
maybe the let's say five years let's
hope it's it's not ten to to see what
what are the answers um
some people will largely believe in
unsupervised or self-supervised learning
of single modalities
and then crossing them
some people might think end-to-end
learning is the answer
modularity is maybe the answer so we
don't know but
we're just definitely excited to find
out but it feels like this is the right
time and we're at the beginning of this
position we're finally ready to do these
kind of general
big models and agents
what do you sort of specific technical
thing about gato flamingo
chinchilla
gopher any of these that is especially
beautiful that was surprising
maybe is there something that just jumps
out at you
of course there's the general thing of
like you didn't think it was possible
and then
you realize it's possible in terms of
the generalizability across modalities
and all that kind of stuff or maybe the
how small of a network relatively
speaking gato is all that kind of stuff
but is is there some weird
little things that were surprising
look i
i'll give you an answer that's very
important because
maybe people
don't quite realize this but
the teams behind these efforts the
actual humans yeah that's maybe the
surprising
um in a obviously positive way so
anytime you see these these
breakthroughs i mean it's easy to map it
to a few people there's people that are
great at explaining things and so on
that's that's very nice but
maybe the the the learnings or the
method learnings that i get as a human
about this is um sure we can move
forward um
and but the surprising bit is how
how important are all the pieces of of
these projects
how do they come together so i'll give
you
maybe some of the ingredients of success
that are common across these um but not
the obvious ones and machine learning i
i can always always also give you those
but
basically
there is
engineering is it's critical so so very
good engineering uh because ultimately
we're we're collecting
um data sets right so the the
engineering of data and then of
deploying the models at scale
into some compute cluster that cannot go
understated that is a huge factor of
success um and it's hard to believe that
details matter so much
we would like to believe that it's true
that there is more and more of a
standard formula as i was saying like
this recipe that works for everything
but then when you zoom into this each of
these projects then you realize the the
the devil is indeed in the details and
then the teams
have to work kind of together towards
these goals
so
engineering of data and obviously
clusters and large scale is very
important and then
one that is often
not maybe nowadays it is more more clear
is
benchmark progress right so we're
talking here about multiple months of
you know tens of researchers um and and
and people that are trying to organize
the research and so on working together
and
you don't know that you can get there i
mean it is this this is this is the
beauty like if you're not risking to
trying to do something that feels
impossible you're not gonna get there
but you need the way to measure progress
so the benchmarks that you build are
critical um i've seen this beautifully
play out in many projects i mean um
maybe the one i've seen it more
consistently which means we we
established the metric
actually the community did and then we
leveraged that massively is alpha fault
this is a project where
the data the metrics were all there and
all it took was and it's easier said
than done an amazing team working
not to try to find some incremental
improvement and publish which which is
one way to do research that is valid but
aim very high and work literally for
years
to iterate over that process and working
for years with the team i mean
it is it is tricky that also happened
happened to happen partly during a
pandemic and so on um so i think my meta
learning from all these is
the teams are critical to the success
and then if now going to the machine
learning the part that's surprising
is
um
so we like architectures like neural
networks um and i would say this was a
very rapidly evolving field until the
transformer came so
attention might indeed be all unique
which is the title also a good title
although
in hindsight is good i don't think at
the time i thought this is a great title
for a paper but
that that architecture is proving that
the dream of modeling sequences of any
bites
there is something there that will stick
and and i think these these advance in
architectures in in kind of how neural
networks are architecture to do what
they do
um it's been hard to find one that has
been so stable and relatively has
changed very little
since it was invented
five or so years ago so that is a
surprising keeps is a surprise that
keeps recurring into other projects try
to
on a philosophical or technical level
introspect what is the magic of
attention
what is what is the tension
that's attention in people that study
cognition so human attention
i think there's giant wars over what
attention means
how it works in the human mind so what
this very simple looks at what attention
is in your network
from the days of attention is all you
need but broad do you think there's a
general principle that's that's really
powerful here yeah so a distinction
between transformers and lstms which
were what came before and and you know
there was a transitional period where
you could you could use both in fact
when we talked about alpha star we used
transformers and lstms so it was still
the beginning of transformers they were
very powerful but lstms were still very
also very powerful sequence models
so
the power of the transformer
is that it has built in
what we call an inductive bias of
attention
that makes the model when when you think
of a sequence of integers right like we
discussed this before right this is a
sequence of words
um
when you when you have to do very hard
tasks over these words this could be
we're gonna translate a whole paragraph
or we're gonna predict the next
paragraph given ten paragraphs before
there's some
loose
intuition from how we do it as a human
that is very
nicely mimicked and re like replicated
structurally speaking in the transformer
which is this idea of
you're looking for something
right so you're sort of when you're you
you you just read a piece of text now
you're thinking what comes next
you might want to re-look at the text or
look it from scratch i mean
literally is is because there's no
recurrence you're just thinking what
comes next and it's almost hypothesis
driven right so if if i'm thinking the
next word that i'll write is cat or doc
okay um
the way the transformer works
almost philosophically is it
has these two hypotheses is it is it
gonna be cat or is it gonna be dark and
then
it says okay if it's cat i'm gonna look
for certain words not necessarily cat
although cat is an obvious word you
would look in the past to see whether it
makes more sense to output cat or dog
and then it does some very
deep computation over the words and
beyond right so it combines the words
and
but
but it has the query as we call it that
is cat
and then similarly for doc right and so
it's it's very it's a very computational
way to think about
look if i'm if i'm thinking deeply about
text i need to go back to to look at all
the text attend over it but it's not
just attention like what what is guiding
the attention and that was the key
inside from an earlier paper is not
how far away is it i mean how far away
is it is important what what what did i
just write about that's critical but
what you wrote about
10 pages ago might also be critical
so
you're looking not positionally but
content-wise right and you
transformers have this beautiful way to
query for certain content and pull it
out
in a compressed way so then you can make
a more informed decision i mean that's
one way to explain transformers
but i think it's it's very it's a very
powerful inductive bias
there might be some details that might
change over time but
i think that is
what makes transformers so much more
powerful than the recurrent networks
that were more recently biased based
which obviously works in some tasks but
it has major flaws transformer itself
has flaws
and i think the main one the main
challenge is these prompts that we we
just were talking about
they can be a thousand words long but if
i'm teaching you starcraft i mean i'll
have to show you videos i have to i have
to point you to whole wikipedia articles
about the game um we'll have to interact
probably as you play you'll ask me
questions the context require for us to
achieve
me being a good teacher to you on the
game as you would want to do it with a
model
what i think goes well beyond the
current capabilities um so the question
is how do we benchmark this and then how
do we change the structure of the
architectures i think there's ideas on
both sides but
we'll have to see empirically right
obviously what ends up working
and as as you talked about some of the
ideas could be you know keeping the
constraint
of that length in place but then forming
like hierarchical representations
to where you can stop being much clever
in how you use those thousand tokens
yeah that's really interesting but it
also is possible that this attention
mechanism where you basically you don't
have a recency bias but you you you look
more generally you you make it learnable
the mechanism in which way you look back
into the past you make that learnable
it's also possible where at the very
beginning of that
because
that
you might become smarter and smarter in
the way
you query the past
uh
so recent past and distant past and
maybe very very distant path so almost
like the attention mechanism
will have to
improve and evolve as good as the
uh the
tokenization mechanism where so you can
represent long-term memory somehow yes
and i mean hierarchies are are very i
mean it's a very nice word that sounds
appealing
there's lots of work adding hierarchy to
the memories um in practice
it does seem like we keep coming back to
the main formula or main
architecture
that sometimes tells us something
there's such a sentence that a friend of
mine told me like whether it wants to
work or not so
transformer was clearly an idea that
wanted to work and then
i think there's some principles we
believe will be needed but finding the
exact details details matter so much
right that's gonna be tricky i love the
idea that there's
like
you as a
human being you want you want some ideas
to work and then there's the model that
wants some ideas to work and you get to
have a conversation to see which
more likely the model will win in the
end
because it's the one you don't have to
do any work the model is the one that's
to do the work so you should listen to
the model
you